if y'all could smell this right now
it's cooking cooking hot
yo what's up this is drewski and these
are my 10 Essentials
[Music]
number one I gotta have my camo man camo
is a big part of my life I'm a Georgia
Boy so you know country boy I think I
was always in the camera for a while man
a lot of people trying to take my steel
now so might gotta switch that up a bit
you know got a my own brand of camo I
think this is even a ski mask camel
right here so if you're on your sheisty
you can't go wrong with Bass Pro this is
super cool to have on your boat you take
a gander down there the lake yeah at
least come in handy no I don't I don't
fish man I think my last time fishing I
had a bad experience and it was a lot of
those buck flies those big bucks I
definitely haven't gone back
no you guys went through my notebook
yeah I went through this notebook
I need this this is my life in here man
this is all the jokes all the written
goals everything you know I jot down and
like yeah like monthly goals yearly
goals you just gotta have this to like
release your mind sometimes literally
everything's in here Coulda would have
shut his stuff put tour for lifers
that's a good question we're not looking
for man right now we're looking for
a certain body type it has nothing to do
with music or an executive all that
other I'm looking for a certain
body type right now that I could have
been recorded So
once I see that narrow it down
ah the snowboard man I don't care
about that
jewelry
I'll have a big stash of jewelry yet all
right I'm just getting started a Rolex
playing Jane can't go wrong gift of my
birthday for my management and my team I
wanted to bust down
but uh you know all that about
depreciation and all that get that bus
down soon don't worry about it Priceless
right here pretty Priceless this chain
was also a gift from icebox yeah this
means a lot to me man this is you know
this is for the team this wasn't
necessarily just for me this is for the
company that we're building right now
and you know this is a big deal so this
is also Priceless huh y'all come on both
sides
so like I said this chain was you know
this is like gang appreciation huh how
do you feel about this huh definitely
one of my first trophies of the team I
appreciate that uh how you feel about
that
[Music]
you know for life is a great company man
we're building as a production company
so yeah now that that that chain
definitely means a lot you know
[Music]
I have a bad addiction with both of
these my ear has started bleeding from
using these too much and my mom
literally like tells me like yo you need
to stop around with that
it's like a drug it feels so good maybe
you want to pop one open huh
these bad boys huh
oh
you know sometimes I feel so
good you pop one of these off stick the
whole thing yeah that hurts I don't
think Q-tips are good for you this is
actually good for you flossing I think
more people should do it keep your smile
and it actually keeps your breath not
smelling like A lot of people don't
know that
is
that is these are precious to me these
are my babies I wear these all the time
this leggings has been a lot man you
know
when you're up in size there's something
called chafing but for all y'all out
there in the world
get you some of these
it's good for chafing nah but honestly
this is like a style for me like I truly
enjoy wearing leggings you gotta have
some short shorts to follow up for
diesel sometimes when I wear shorts I
like to show off the tats and stuff I
just got this top this could have been
records one yeah let's go this could
have been right here's time so now I'm
not really wearing leggings because I
got to show this you know
big CEO don't worry about it
this is much needed man on the road this
causes a lot of arguments a lot of
fights you know anybody that tours knows
that you have to have a game system of
some kind I had to be Xbox but it could
be
some type of game system because this
brings everybody together yeah
but it's Incognito I'll be custom
out on that they don't
even know it's me some people have ass
though some of those kids on there be
like yo is this like nah this
ain't jerky
this
I actually smelled this on a girl so
this is a men's cologne though I smell
this on a girl and very peculiar smell
now everybody's gonna take my son
I should have brought some
going on here that I've been like
eventually the room you'll spawn in a
second if you haven't already yeah hot
sex man but honestly I love this cologne
and I think more people should also work
alone the stuff I was going through I
went through like acts and all that I
almost burnt down the house spraying too
much ax it's flammable we're spraying
that and Jim like a
dog
these been through Jerusalem man
look at these
I'm walking like Jesus and these
but you gotta have these man
Birkenstocks they're like the Holy Grail
they mold to your foot and actually
these are molded from foot sweat they
mold to your foot but this is actually
there's
there's damn I should have bought some
new pair before I bought these in there
huh if y'all could smell this right
now it's cooking
cooking hot
ah my prize possession trophy so I won
this at a dance competition at the
church I go to Voices of Faith I was in
a dance competition in second grade and
I've always kept this by my side it's
always inspired me I take this very
seriously though yeah
[Music]
thank you for the dance competition
make sure you be careful with this
[Music]
this water right here is so goddamn good
nothing like it truly um
ionized hydration 9.5 or higher purified
water electrolytes for days I knew that
when people start putting like this
on water they know what the they
talking about you know what I'm saying
this ain't no they're not going
they're not going to say nutrition facts
you know what I'm saying there's 12
fluid ounces in here they put sodium in
this
it's five milligrams of sodium in here
all right this might not be the best
water for you 5 mg all right
yeah man
that keeps some dice on I'm big on dice
I've always got keys on dysons for real
like I got gambling and like all the
I'll be involved in nah boys
so that's that
kids don't shoot dice
[Music]